hello everyone this is the vice
president of internet infidels edward
tomesian and today i have a very special
guest who i've already interviewed
before and his name is bill gatey and uh
he used to be an ex-cuban spy and now he
is a physicist
and uh before we get into the question
sir did you want to add anything to your
introduction
uh yeah maybe a couple things since i
guess we're gonna be talking about carl
sagan we're going to be talking about uh
tesseract's hypercubes right
and i just wanted to mention that i was
a fan
of carl sagan
during many years
i stopped being a fan
uh for essentially three reasons first
of all i think he was an excellent
teacher okay
and so that captivated me you know that
that really caught my attention
but uh but he had three things that i
eventually grew out of and one of them
was he was an atheist i'm no longer an
atheist
he was a um a
person who supported quantum mechanics
and general relativity essentially you
know
mathematical physics
uh
i
fight with teeth and nail tooth and nail
against uh mathematical physics
everything that's happened in the last
100 years
especially last 400 years really i'm
saying there's a different scientific
method the scientific method we have
today is uh irrational and
carl sagan supported that scientific
method and mathematical physics and the
third reason is that he
uh
and i as well like 30 40 years ago
thought we were going to go to the stars
that we were going to make contact with
another civilization et cetera et cetera
and today i think uh we're going to go
extinct very soon humans are going to go
out
yeah so everyone
i no longer am a fan of carlson yeah and
everyone uh he's got uh some videos and
some uh
uh website links to uh pages about the
extension of man i thought they were
interesting you can all check that on
online and um alrighty so we'll begin
the first question
maybe may i say one more thing yeah go
ahead go ahead the reason i have a beard
i just came from vacation
and so i haven't even had time to shave
so sorry it's all right it's all right
we got it and uh just to clarify um for
everyone uh though bill gates said he he
wasn't an atheist that doesn't mean he's
a theist either he has an interesting
position so i just want to clarify yeah
because when most people say i'm not an
atheist they think oh like he's a theist
but yeah but he's not that either he's a
mystery part he's he's he's
got an interesting opportunity i created
a new uh category there you go yep we're
all about innovation that's that's what
we need these days all righty so going
into our first question
so i recently watched a video of carl
sagan talking about a four dimensional
tesseracts and it was interesting just
to give a brief um summarization of what
he was saying he was saying suppose
there's two deers and they're living in
a 2d universe and they're conscious and
that you have motion but um they have
they're comprised of length and width
but no height and he said well you know
these cards that i have have a little
bit of height but let's just assume
there's no heights just length and width
and he says you know uh two deters kind
of like moving around and suddenly you
know a three deer
from like a parallel dimension or
whatever
yeah once the parallel universe wants to
make contact with them and then the
theater is like hey you know um
can you see me and he was like uh you
know like the two deer thinks he's
hallucinating hearing voices and
suddenly he the three deer makes himself
known into the 2d universe of course
they can't when the three deer comes
into the 2d universe you know
since you can't have height in the 2d
universe the the 2d are seeing the 3d
are not in the same way that we would
see the 3d or so it's like kind of like
segments of just length and without
height like oh okay so it's like i see
something but uh i don't exactly
understand what
the you know three dimensions are i only
know back and forth and the three deer
is like well you don't know up and down
he's like no i've never heard of like
which direction is that i don't know
what up and down is it's like all right
i guess i'm gonna have to show you so
the three deer comes in and pulls the
two deer
out of this
universe very interesting and then he's
like and then the the two deer magically
uh is comprised of height now it's like
oh i know what up and down is and then
yeah and that's what he said it was very
interesting and so carl single was like
well just imagine that we're in a
similar predicament to the two deer
we're in a three-dimensional universe
and suppose that a four-dimensional
being wants to make contact with us and
they say hey you know there's a
um
a fourth manner in which an object can
face that's mutually perpendicular to
length within height there's a fourth
mutually perpendicular direction and
we're like what the heck is that like uh
you're saying that you know like just
imagine a ball and you have all these
arrows putting outside of it it
literally comprises of every single
direction you can think of and he's like
well there's a direction other than the
direction there
and i'm like that's all the directions
there are he's like no i'm gonna have to
show you i guess i'm not to show you and
then so he takes me into the four
dimensional universe and allegedly i can
comprehend what this other direction is
and i'm like you know i i i almost think
carl sagan's starting point is
fallacious because like i think you
brought it up too you can elaborate it
on it later um
i'll just end off with when with two
deers like in order to have motion there
has to be an object that like occupies
you know space a hypothetical region of
space like you can't have motion without
objects that exist out here so it's like
i'm wondering how he can envision
objects moving without height with them
and it's just like the fact that the two
dealers are conscious can you have
consciousness in 2d it would seem like
you need a brain or something 3d to have
consciousness so like i just think the
starting point is kind of irrational to
begin with like just because you can't
go to 2d to 3d you can't go to 3d to 4d
so yeah what do you think about this let
you chime in there i i think you did
pretty good uh summarizing uh i i can
let me do a summary myself also of what
that video says it's like a seven eight
minute video and uh this is essentially
what he says so i'm gonna be addressing
these issues that he raises um he says
astronomers say space is curved and the
universe is finite but unbounded
whatever are they talking about that's
how he begins his video right then he
goes into the analogy of using flat land
okay so he says it has width and length
but no height no mystic dimension called
up right then he goes through all these
steps he says he starts uh because he's
gonna end up with this hypercube he
wants to explain how you construct or
how they ended up with a hypercube or
otherwise known as a tesseract so he
says it imagine the shadow of a cube in
2d okay so you so just think of a cube
right and you point a shadow well you
get something more or less as far as he
was concerned like a square okay so
that's the idea he's got he says the
square is a shadow of a cube in 2d right
that's how he starts so he he wants to
prepare your mind so he's going to take
you through all these little steps right
he says now imagine a direction at right
angles to length width and height you're
remember you're a 2d right and now
you're going to have to uh
look at an uh direction
at right angles to length with and
height and like you said you know it's
unimaginable you cannot imagine at least
in our 3d world and they say well yeah
of course because we're puny 3d beings
like
just like that too dear yeah so so like
they didn't understand what up was they
didn't understand what uh height was in
the same way we can uh
imagine or understand what this uh uh
uh dimension which is perpendicular to
all three known dimensions right uh is
we cannot imagine it okay so he said but
imagine that there is a fourth physical
direction and he and he admits he says i
can't show you what direction that is he
says it okay
but imagine that there is a fourth
physical dimension okay so let's concede
let's say okay let's imagine that there
is one i cannot visualize it but let's
concede the assumption okay yeah he said
we would generate a four-dimensional
hypercube also called a tesseract i
cannot show you a test right because i
am trapped in three dimensions okay so
he again confesses
i can show you the shadow the shadow
of a 4d hypercube a 3d shadow right and
he's saying that
nested cube so he's got one cube inside
the other one the famous tesseract the
picture that he's got out there okay
uh
there's several problems here
several several problems i want to go
through each one of them the first one
is that mathematical dimensions have
nothing at all to do with physical
dimensions
in physics it's straightforward it's
baby stuff it's kindergarten stuff
length with height we're done yeah
and and what are those we are saying
these are directions which are
perpendicular to each other first of all
they're 90 degrees to each other
and any object that is 3d we say that an
object is three-dimensional because it
can point in the and three in these
three mutually perpendicular directions
we're done okay
that's where it stops for physics is
very simple kindergarten stuff
that's not what a dimension what a
coordinate or what a vector is for the
purposes of mathematics
mathematics defines a dimension
as the number
of coordinates
number of coordinates necessary to
locate a point within an object
so if you have uh let me give you an
option it's a very simple object here we
have a ruby cube we've got a cube okay
so a dimension in the in mathematics is
not length width and height that's
that's baby stuff for them they don't
care for that they say a dimension is
the number of
uh coordinates that you need to locate a
point within this box within this cube
so so if i need three coordinates to
locate a point within it or on the
surface of it or whatever then it's
three-dimensional that's that's the
notion
and so we've got a problem
because of the following
dimension in physics again because
they're going to translate they're going
to
extrapolate their notion to physics
that's where the problem is if they kept
it within mathematics we could care less
but they they're going to extrapolate
that into physics that's where we run
into trouble
and and this is where the problem is a
dimension has to do with
objects with uh the way an object points
or tilts or faces
coordinate has to do
with the location of an object with
respect to some reference frame for
example this box with respect to this
room so i can say what is the location
of this box well for that i use
coordinates okay and i don't use length
with height i use
latitude
and altitude so i say well there's uh i
i have uh one direction and this is all
qualitative by the way i have one
direction going up up and down the other
one going sideways and the other one
going towards me
and those are the only three that i can
imagine i cannot imagine a fourth
dimension to this okay that's the first
problem so a dimension is not a
coordinate a coordinate is not a
dimension dimension is used for tilt for
uh orientation it's for for objects
coordinates is for the location of an
object
vector is neither one a vector
has to do with um
motion
it's a dynamic concept vector means that
you're going to be moving
uh breath
elevation and uh what's the other one
and um
i forgot the other one the first one uh
like length but it's not length it's
known as um
uh depth so you have depth breath and
elevation yeah those are the three
vectors of physics
okay they have nothing to do with
latitude longitude and uh altitude which
have nothing to do with length width and
height
yeah
three different types of concepts what
the what the mathematicians have done
is they bunch them all together because
they don't care about qualitative stuff
and they said look
what what they really are talking about
is number lines
number lines what dimensions don't have
and dimensions have what number lines
don't have a number line only has
magnitude and has no direction numbers
don't go in any direction you can point
the numbers in any direction you want
because numbers have even in curves if
you want because numbers only increase
but they always put that little arrow in
those cartesian coordinates you know and
they put them in straight lines and they
say they they give you the impression
that it's got direction
yeah one of those and one of those are
going to replace which is height
or
altitude whichever one you want and
they're going to replace that with time
and they're going to say look we put all
the other three dimensions into one
dimension we call it space
and that's your three dimension and then
the other one is going to be time
but time doesn't run perpendicular to
anything
so you cannot put time with length you
cannot put time with with you cannot put
time with uh height
and just redefining dimension
yeah the question here is an issue of
definitions what is a dimension and
again
mathematics is very different than a uh
dimension for physics that's the first
problem
okay so once we get a handle on that
then we have another problem because
this uh
carl sagan says look
uh the shadow of a four-dimensional
tesseract which we cannot imagine a
hypercube we cannot imagine or
hypersphere you can also which is a
little more complicated you cannot
imagine that but a shadow of that in our
3d world looks like a nest a pair of
nested uh cubes one inside the other one
bigger than the other that's essentially
the notion and the uh corners of those
are united by
time that's what time is
that's the fourth dimension which is
perpendicular according to them in the
fourth dimension right perpendicular to
three what's the problem with that what
these people are saying is you take a
cube take this cube right
and you expand it in every direction uh
like radially right so so you're going
to expand it in every direction that's
how you end up with a nested cube one
bigger than the other but what are those
lines that unite the vertices those are
time that's time that you're talking
about so a hypercube so-called hypercube
or the shadow of the hypercube in our 3d
world
is a box that is expanding through time
it's a movie
of a box expanding that's what they're
talking about that's uh that's their con
concept of a tesseract of a
an expanding cube they take that movie
and so you have this movie that's
expanding okay so we have the movie
that's expanding right so far the box is
expanding so you have a movie of that
now they do something even worse
now they're going to rotate the
tesseract
so now they're going to not only is this
box expanding through time meaning
you've got motion there you're talking
about a film but now you're going to
rotate
now seeing
of time and three of space because you
need one where the box expands and the
other one when it where it rotates you
got two motions
and so now now we're talking about a
five-dimensional box here
two of time and three of space yeah
that's what they did that's conceptually
what they're talking about and this this
is the problem i got with what sagan is
saying and uh relativists in general
they want to give you an idea that space
time is four-dimensional let's assume
that's the case what is the fourth
dimension time they tell you okay that's
that's the
worldly wisdom out there whether they
declared it or not whether they believe
it or not it doesn't matter but that's
the fourth dimension as far as ninety
percent at least of the people out there
are concerned okay we have this fourth
dimension which is time again they put
it perpendicular to length within height
which is space
that's already irrational because time
does not run perpendicular to anything
you know my they say well it runs
forward well uh ed what's your forward
your forward is my my backward i guess i
i go
forward is against your forward so
which direction does your time run
forward or backward or sideways or
upwards i mean what is that it's
nonsense that's what it is
you know they they ran around in circles
with their own uh
definitions
and uh again they're using number lines
and they're calling them dimensions
coordinates and vectors when they're you
when they're really talking about number
lines
number lines have no direction number
lines have no perpendicularity
dimensions coordinates and vectors have
perpendiculary
and um uh what is it and direction what
they don't have is magnitude
they're qualitative concepts so
never though twins shall mean
coordinates will never or dimension will
never match number lines and vice versa
yeah gotcha yeah i know and it's kind of
like when he was saying that i was like
um about the four dimensional tesseract
it kind of it's kind of like him saying
like well in the four-dimensional world
imagine the clock that can spin in a
direction that isn't clockwise or
counterclockwise it's like it's like but
like which direction is like there
that's all i can spin he's like well you
just live in a 3d universe where the
clock can only spin in two directions in
the 4d universe it can spin in three and
you're just like that's all the ways an
object can spin it's like it's just so
similar with the tesseract it's like the
the most of object can face is in three
directions like if you have a ball with
arrows pointing out of them on every
side of it like a ball but this the
arrow ball like that's literally every
direction and he's saying well there's a
direction that's different than that but
that that summarizes all the directions
like it doesn't make any sense well the
issue here and and you more or less
touched upon it just not now
it's unimaginable and they say well of
course it's unimaginable because that's
a fourth dimensional world and we're
stuck in the 30d world but the issue is
i got to talk to you and you're a
three-dimensional being
they cannot make an assumption that's
outside of our experience in that sense
in the sense that it's uh even
unimaginable you cannot imagine
falsifying
so you know if you cannot imagine if
like uh sagan says here he says it twice
he says i cannot show you what direction
that is and then he says i cannot show
you a tesseract because i am trapped in
three dimensions so if he cannot imagine
it
what's his theory well well what if it's
not conceivable it's not believable yeah
yeah i mean i'd rather believe in god
than to believe in the tesseract
yeah
not to the tesseract that's unimaginable
you gotta know that you know a guy with
a yeah exactly
that's what i was telling
i'll tell my friend jason
at least like with a miracle you can at
least imagine like the motions of like
jesus raising someone from the dead like
don't fight or him flying into heaven
yeah like you can imagine now that it's
like how does the conclusion follow from
the theory like how is that possible
that's something else but at least you
can conceive of it but like with a 4d
tesseract you can't conceive of it it's
like in the same category of a circle
square like if you can't conceive of it
it's not even possible you know yeah no
and again uh the important thing here is
that
and i want to emphasize this again
that the projection of the because they
say yeah we're not in the 4d world we
cannot imagine it fine okay let's
concede that but they're talking about
the shadow of the tesseract in our world
and when they put that shadow and they
say a nested cube one inside the other
they're talking about motion because
those vertices that are connected
those are that's time that line there
represents time okay yeah true and so if
that's time to talk about motion and if
they rotate that whole hyper cue as you
will see it everywhere that they rotate
the hypercube now we have this thing is
expanding they take a snapshot of that
now they rotate it now the the other one
for the next shot they have to have it
expand again and they rotate expanse
rotate so they're talking about two
motions two times
simultaneously
yeah that's yeah that's interesting
what i'm talking about is they're nested
times
gotcha gotcha all righty all right well
that was a good summarization yeah he
kind of had some of the same concerns as
i did so yeah thanks for explaining that
for us and then uh for our last question
today um and we touched about it in our
other uh interview we had is about your
life as a spy and uh so so from what i
understand so you grew up in argentina
and then joined the communist party and
uh you know that was you know go you
know you like that and you know life was
good more or less at least
in your head because you you're
you sympathize with it at the time right
so yeah yeah yeah yeah
gotcha oh yeah understand yeah and so
then later on you ended up moving up to
california and you joined uh advanced
micro devices and you ended up working
up your way to like the head engineer
uh i was a manager of a whole shift i
had surprises engineers technicians all
under me yeah
awesome and then uh the job was known as
facilitator but it was a manager a whole
shift manager for the thin films area i
worked in oh gotcha gotcha all righty
and then while you were doing that uh
you were giving information from amd to
the cubans
yeah for many and then after all the way
all the way till to approximately
1979.
oh wow okay
all righty and then for 13 years
oh okay alrighty and then so then when
you were doing that um you know you
received uh notoriety and stuff from uh
what you were doing and then eventually
you ended up joining a clan stein
operation in which um you went to south
america and gave some of the information
you received from amd to some chinese
and iranians in south america well we
have to understand uh intermediate steps
they're important to understand why that
happened uh yes it did happen but let me
explain what happened what happened
i began working with the fbi because i
turned myself into the cia okay yeah
that's correct yeah i turned myself into
the cia this was in what is it um
1992. in
august of 1992 i turned myself over to
the
cia they uh
delegated me or
[Music]
they uh sent me they sent the fbi to my
house so we started working with the fbi
in what is known as a counter espionage
operation okay so i worked with them for
about two years okay
and during that time i uh got into intel
corporation thanks to using them as a
reference i use the fbi as a fbi agent
indeed intel
when you look at all this how how the
world works it's just funny out there a
lot of people don't know how all these
organizations work you know when i
turned myself into the cia
essentially because some cubans asked
some cuban military um uh
intelligence officers asked me to turn
myself in and i said they're gonna put
me in prison they said no they're going
to work with you and that's exactly what
happened you would think that you're
present no they don't they work with you
and that's what happened and so when i
turned myself to the cia into my the cia
they sent me over to the fbi or the fbi
came to my house etc and we started
working with them what happened was they
had to keep the cubans the cuban uh
intelligence service
continued to believe that i was for real
that nothing had changed in my life
oh okay yeah
so they they kept so they they gave me
information so you were a double agent
double agent and so at that point they
gave me information to give to the
cubans
[Laughter]
and the information was from um inter
corporation
that's okay
that's gotcha
but so so that's why intel got a little
upset when they found out about me
because you know they they
uh first of all what was happening was
amd was looking for me everywhere and
they couldn't find that
but they knew that i was with the fbi
that the fbi knew where i was and the
fbi said look we cannot tell you where
he's at because we're working on a
secret counter espionage operation so
they would not tell amd what happened
was amd put a like a wanted poster of
some kind
at the uh semiconductor association in
california which is very big over there
and uh
to that semiconductor uh organization or
association
intel belonged to that amd and so many
other companies what happened was
the um
security manager of intel his name was
steve lund he goes up there and he sees
the wanted poster says oh i'm going to
look to see if this guy if i can find
him it turns out oh [ __ ] he comes back
he says this guy's working for us
and that's where the whole thing blew up
in the face
yeah
because they said hold it this guy's
working at intel and the and fb fbi did
not tell us about it so they contacted
the fbi and they said look
this this guy he's a spy he's working
for us
and yeah he's claimed that told them
before
the fbi says yeah we know
and so the fight was intel was saying
you guys didn't tell us and the fbi said
yeah we told you
yeah that's what i was saying fbi
claimed that but then until yeah i
remember the interview on fox news the
guy was like if we would have known bill
gatey was doing a
operation there's no way we would have
hired him that would have been first i
can't believe the fbi said that
in fact i've got a recording effect i
think in that same interview i gave him
that recording and i talked with um
what's his name um
the fbi agent uh jim jim king he was the
fbi agent in austin texas
and
i have a phone conversation with him
which i record i recorded everything i
could and in that conversation i tell
him look you know i managed to get into
intel like secretly and he said well i
don't think there's not much that could
be showing up on your record that intel
could find out about and so
obviously obviously
[Music]
the fbi had not told intel that i was
working for them what happened was that
when they found out about me they put
the pr steve lund put the pressure on me
to uh cooperate quotations with an
internal investigation okay
journal investigation was an external
investigation they were trying to
collect information for amd that's what
was happening amd was
they wanted to kill me they wanted to
murder me and they were looking all over
for for me and intel you know i think
took the opportunity to say well you
know you signed a confidentiality
agreement you also are working for us
and it says there that you must
cooperate with any internal
uh investigation and they were starting
to ask me questions about what happened
at amd and i said screw you i can't and
and i asked the fbi what do i tell them
and the guys at the fbi told me look
tell them that you cannot cooperate
because you're uh working in a
counter-espionage operation that's what
i told them but they wouldn't buy it
you got to cooperate so i was between
the sword and the wall that's
essentially that yeah
and uh at one point interesting
because i saw it coming you know i said
i better i get i better get some
insurance and so i started copying i i
logged on to the
i was in phoenix arizona and i went down
to the uh database in albuquerque new
mexico where they had the pentium the
all the specs
and rather than download them which
would you know throw in all the belts
i filmed it i filmed
i spent
a whole weekend saturday and sunday 12
hours each day that's how much i copied
you can imagine and what i did was i ran
the the specs and filmed i ran the spec
i had my camera there on a tripod and
this film film film film i put them in
three cassettes
and um and then we went on vacation with
my wife to
greece you had to go to greece for
different things
and it turns out that um
intel was following me around
and they discovered i had a storage
under the name of bill green i had all
kinds of fake documents and so on
under the name bill green
and
someone
broke into the storage lockers
they broke into 10 lockers
among the mine which was the first one
really mine was the first locker so they
broke into mine
miracle they didn't take all my gold
coins that i had there they missed it
but they did find the cassettes and
that's apparently what they wanted so it
was kind of strange that you know they
broke into the storage
we come back from greece and uh and we
discovered that someone broke into the
storage
and uh
you know i had the uh police from the fb
uh from the uh phoenix uh police they
wanted to talk to me i said you want to
talk to me they robbed me and you want
to talk to me now why don't you talk to
the guy who robbed me you know kind of
thing
the way the story goes because this is
this is what intel told me the the the
tapes ended up in the hands of steve
lund
the manager the security manager for
intel and so because of that they fired
me they fired me but
it turns out that among the tapes they
found out i had been filming the fbi and
the cia for two years
yeah you were filming the fbi like in
your oven you had like a video cassette
you put it in your oven that was just
one of them i mean
i went with a little recorder even to
the cia which it would have cost me my
life probably because
uh when i got there the uh there was a
one of these guys uh agents from the
cia he came out with a gun in his hand
he said put your hands on top of that
card whoa
so i put my hands on top of the car but
he was born
yeah but he was more scared than i was i
guess he probably thought i had a bomb
or something i don't know and so
he uh me
and he missed the recorder which was in
my underwear
anticipated that yeah but it wasn't
gonna go i didn't think
i didn't think they were gonna treat me
like that i thought i was just going to
walk in like anybody no no they frisked
me so when you walked into the cia they
were like
yo yeah
dang you're like i'm hey i'm coming my
on my own
i guess i didn't care
yeah because i i hadn't all day asking
to talk to a case agent and when i got
there that's the reception i got and so
when the guy frisked me says okay walk
through those doors i went through those
doors and there was a lady
and she was she was apparently she had
uh some kind of makeup she had a
costume on really uh she was dressed up
with different hair and so on i i i was
convinced she she was dressed up and so
she said okay uh why are you here and i
told her you know that i was giving uh
information from the cuban intelligence
service to them
and i told them everything that you know
i had done i confessed
and she said okay we're gonna be in
contact with you and i love that's it
nothing more happening than that 45 days
later i get the fbi at my home
so
from that time on i had been recording
because you know i said yeah
i kind of happened
you
yeah
everything denied having knowing me at
first and they said yeah we know them
but we see at first they said we caught
a spy what do you mean you caught us by
i was working for you
and then they said look uh um
in a
signature so
they were screwed from every point of
view and so yeah we had all that
information when i when eventually i
went to court uh the prosecutors had to
deal with me because you know it's like
i say they had me buy the balls and i
had them buy the balls
did they accept the uh the video
recording is evidence in the oven
oh yeah
yeah okay i'm sure that helped out like
i knew i had them by the balls so they
had them and after that that's when they
the fbi had to admit they compensated
you i think 607 dollars and 16 cents for
uh dealing with counter intelligence
they they uh they gave me a little more
than that
yeah some of them was cash and so on so
uh we had different dealings with them
okay but uh the issue is that you know
these people uh they thought that you
know that when the prosecutors got me uh
they said you know we have to reach an
agreement with him and the way they
squeezed me because there was no law
really to prosecute me
like who yeah
that's interesting
see they were they were going to hit me
with a national stolen properties act
national
properties act was originally made for
bonnie and clyde and uh
john dillinger people who would steal a
car
cross the state line and they couldn't
follow them so so what happened was
uh
the sheriff on the other side had to
deal with it and but the crime was
committed here so they had no no uh
jurisdiction and that's when they came
up with the stolen properties act and it
became a federal offense for example to
steal the car and take it across state
lines then they put helicopters then
they put uh motorcycles and so on they
had all kinds of vehicles and then they
used it also for
intangibles for
information but see information you
cannot take it across state land what
does it mean to state information to
take information across statements
so they had no real law they were they
were using a stealing law for
intangibles for copyright stuff and it
didn't make any sense but the way they
pressured me is first not through that
statute but mainly through the mail
fraud statue one on the one hand and if
you ever read the mail fraud statue you
can catch any fly with that i mean
even breathing is a crime under that
statute it's got so many semicolons and
and commas that it's just unbelievable
if you do this if you do that it and if
this and if that it's just unbelievable
that was one issue the other issue was
they went after my wife and uh
yeah so they were going to put her
in prison so i said look let's reach an
agreement we reached an agreement that's
why i got a lenient service because
uh a sentence because i had them also by
the balls yeah he had that evidence yeah
there's like an agreement there was no
other choice for any of us
yeah yeah i like how it's like uh you
got charged with you know uh a crime but
you know the cia and the fbi like you
know no one punished them even though
they're the ones that you know were
helping you do this and gave you you
know give you the incentive oh well you
know
yeah the issue the issue there is uh one
is that they got off the hook very
lightly because they would have been in
big trouble but as far as the uh issue
in in court
i think i would have won it uh there
were four issues that i raised in my i
put a motion to dismiss that's what it's
called and
the four issues that i raised if i see
if i can remember all four of them one
is that the information did not belong
to intel
it did not belong uh
yeah intel that's what it was um
the information did not belong to intel
even if i would have taken it copied or
whatever
because they never registered it
they have not registered it for several
reasons one is you know you change the
specs every day you're not going to
change the patent law or the copyright
law every every time you change the spec
that's one issue uh and another issue is
that
they don't register processes
because
again processes are secret they want to
have a secret patent and they do have to
this day secret patents nobody knows how
they make them because in order to know
that you've got to work inside the
company and for that you've got to sign
the confidentiality agreement et cetera
et cetera i see okay yeah yeah
and then the other one is that you know
[Music]
a question of jurisdiction
was the crime committed in arizona where
i stole it with quotations or was it in
this transportation across state lines
to california which is uh which gives
the jurisdiction to california
mm-hmm so so what this is interesting
what deals with it is it is the crime
stealing
copying in this case right which they
turn into stealing or is it
transportation of stolen goods
or known to be stolen and they have to
prove that it's stolen and how do you
improve stealing of intangibles
yeah
because yeah if i should do your shoe
you cannot use it that's how you know i
stole it but if i steal your song steal
with quotations i can sing it you can
sing everybody can sing it so yeah yeah
yeah did that cross state lives
yeah yeah yeah
yeah you can see how you can't take a
concept
exactly i think you can't take a concept
from place to place i gotcha that's
interesting and then uh yeah and for
everyone who's interested in some more
further investigation uh bill has a
video of the fox news segment that
covers uh this ordeal that happened many
years ago and uh there's also a video on
amazon prime called el crazy chat which
is based on uh his work for the cia and
uh just to comment on one thing
uh rumor has it that uh your
clandenstein operation was so successful
that fidel castro wanted to meet up with
you in person is that true
uh not only true they paid for our trip
uh all the way to cuba
and we were traded treated like royalty
i mean
but it was so funny because to
circumvent any detection especially from
the united states
uh we had to go to mexico from mexico to
spain they took our passports away gave
us fake argentine passports so they took
our argentine passports uh our real ones
they gave us fake ones that they had
manufactured for us we gave them
pictures etc
at some time in advance from there we
went uh to barcelona barcelona the
vienna from vienna we went by
train
to czechoslovakia for the first time i
entered a communist country
they took our fake argentine passports
away they gave us fake
uh cuban diplomatic passports which were
red
with those we got on chiasa which it was
the airline i don't know i think it
still is from the czechoslovakian
airline from there we flew to canada to
toronto from toronto we flew to
cuba
so we had to do it all right
just to get to cuba
uh had to go to his treasure chest to
get us into cuba
gotcha did you ended up did you end up
meeting him
no uh and again uh i think we know why
we did not end up meeting him they said
that he was busy but i don't think that
was the case
because uh i think what happened was in
the meantime they figured out that we
were not no longer supporting the cuban
revolution
okay so they decided to
uh
essentially uh burn us
but they were gonna burn us by staking a
uh hook into the cia's mouth
so they sent us without us knowing to
this here they so these these uh agents
who said go to the cia and tell them
that we want to overthrow the cuban
government fidel castro and these guys
were working with us and so we had faith
in them but really they were under the
gun uh fidel castro said do this
send these guys to the cia
and
give them some lousy information
and a couple good ones in there but they
put also some fake information in there
defeated to the cia
you see what happened here yeah
naively naively we gave the information
to the cia and when i asked the agents
of the fbi i said well was the
information they gave you good they said
very very good
but it turns out they said it was very
good and i think it was good most of it
but there were a couple
uh fake pieces of information that were
very important for the cuban government
for the cia to swallow
there was uh just to give you an idea
there was a very important man in miami
a rich guy
very friendly with trump uh in those
days i got a photograph of both of them
together
and uh this guy's a rich guy working
with trump
and they said he was a spy for cuba
okay
and so they said hold it all this
information is good
and this guy's a spy
you see the point
yeah okay
swallow that and so
you know the cia had to be very careful
is this guy a spy or not
you know so they had these these issues
uh
and so this is how the agencies play
with each other
okay and it took you a while to kind of
figure that out like it was just after
the fact you're like oh they gave me
some
some bad stuff to give us a conundrum
let me tell you how i found out i had
like all these names and one day i said
i'm going to search these names who they
are and i found this guy because he was
a very popular guy again he went around
with trump
and i said
oh who did this is the guy that i turned
in this guy's a spy so i myself
questioned that i said oh i think that
they fed this one is a fake uh you know
bit of information
interesting
would that would that happen to be
captain jose pepe
no no no no no no
okay no no someone else okay because i
know he was i so i read something about
him too like okay all right that's
another guy that's already
[Music]
interesting yeah i think i remember some
segment of him on like some uh not on
some like video coverage and he was like
getting angry
whatever
yeah that's interesting i mean there's a
there's a lot into this uh but yeah we
covered a good amount so people have a
good idea of like your background and
stuff so that's awesome yeah thanks for
sharing that with us bill
very exciting
unfortunately like like you told me in
the last interview you didn't get any
sexy women it wasn't like the photo film
they didn't give you a sexy partner or
crime like hey here's
six i still have my wife
there you go dude there you go there you
go
there you go all right i know you both
are in one piece that's that's more than
you can ask for
all righty
awesome all right well thanks for
sharing that with us bill and then uh so
to close out um i guess i can just let
you promote yourself you can promote
your youtube channel and if you have any
lectures or anything you can talk to us
about that as well
yeah uh essentially i have a youtube
channel begaty okay and uh
primarily it's a rant against uh
mathematical physics general relativity
quantum mechanics and string theory i'm
very much against those three groups and
i'm saying none of that is science so he
who wants to find out about it will find
out not only my criticism
but what i replace it with
awesome sounds good and you have a book
out there called why god doesn't exist
but it's not it's not
there's also now i was going to say it's
not an atheist rant it's about your
criticism of you know mathematical
physics right
and the reason is the physics is the
science of existence that's why why the
word the title looks like that the other
one that you should mention is that
there's a free book that people can look
at that first and that's the rope
hypothesis and that's okay yeah that's
at my uh website which is rope
hypothesis dot com
awesome sounds good all right thanks
bill and in a couple of minutes i'll
have this downloaded and ready for you
to share
okay well thank you very much ed yeah
thank you have a good day next time yeah
see you next time bye